Put all your experience playing video games to work.
Literally.
You will need video game expertise, writing skills, and dedication.
Optional: A degree in computer science.
Step one: Enter online tournaments...
...where you challenge other gamers for money.
If you're good, you can win your way to a spot in one of the professional tournaments...
...which pay big bucks. We're talking five and six figures.
Step two: Apply to work in customer service for a video game company...
...like starting in the mail room. An entry-level job like this could lead to a game - playing position.
Step three: Apply for a job as a video game tester with a manufacturer.
You'll need to be familiar with many different games and consoles,...
...and demonstrate you can clearly articulate your likes and dislikes.
Practice. Professional gamers play between 6 and 12 hours a day every day.
Step four: Write about video games for a living...
...either by becoming a game reviewer or working for a publisher that prepares game guides.
Step five: Become a gameplay expert.
These are people hired by game manufacturers to go around the country demonstrating new games.
Step six: Become a software developer.
In other words, create your own games.
A degree in computer science can help you land a job in game writing, designing, and programming.
Step seven: Whichever video game job you want, work hard.
As you might imagine, the competition for these positions is intense.
Did you know 72 percent of Americans play video games?